we're told a monkey is swinging from a
tree
on the first swing she passes through an
arc of 24 meters
with each swing she passes through an
arc one half the length of the previous
swing so what's going on here let's say
this is the top of the rope or the vine
that the monkey is swinging from
and so on that first swing i could draw
a little monkey here so this is my
little monkey
so on that first swing the monkey will
go 24 meters so
might do something like this
then that arc is 24 meters and then on
the second swing it would be she'd swing
back it and arc half the length of the
previous swing so then she would come
back and then it would be half the
length and so maybe swing back over here
and then on the next so that would be 12
and then on the next swing she would
swing half of that which would be six
meters so she might swing like this and
that makes sense that's consistent with
our experiences swinging from trees for
those of us who've done that so let's
look at the first choice which
expression gives the total length the
monk the monkey swings in her first n
swings so pause the video and see if you
can do that and you can express it as
actually express it both two ways
express it as a
geometric series but also express it as
the sum of a geometric series if we were
actually evaluate it
so let's do this together so we already
said on the first swing the monkey goes
24
meters
now on the second swing and i gave you a
hint when i said to express it as a
geometric series she swings half that
now i could just write a 12 here but the
half is interesting because that's going
to be my common ratio for my geometric
series every successive swing the arc
length is half the arc length of the
last swing so it's going to be
it's going to be 24
times one-half and then on the next
swing is going to be 24 it's going to be
half of this so it's going to be 24
times one-half times one-half so that's
24 times one-half
to the second power and so this would be
the first three swings notice that the
exponent here we got to the second power
so the first n swings we are going to
get to
24 times one half not to the nth power
but to the n minus 1 power notice after
two swings we only get to 24 times one
half to the first power after three
swings to the second power so after n
swings to the n minus one power
now as i said we don't want to just have
this expression we actually want to know
how do we evaluate this
and the way we evaluate this is we look
at the formula which we've explained and
we've proven in other videos the formula
for finite geometric series
so that tells us and i'll just write
over here the sum
of first
first
n
terms
is
a where a is the first term so that's
going to be our 24 in this situation
it's a
minus
a
times our common ratio already said that
our common ratio is one-half
to the
nth power
so one way i like to remember it is it
is our first term
minus the first term that we didn't
include or minus what would have been
the term right after this
all of that over 1 minus our common
ratio
and there's other ways that you might
have seen this written you could factor
an a out and you might have seen
something like this a times 1 minus r to
the n
all of that over 1 minus r these two are
equivalent but now let's use this so
this is going to be equal to actually
i'll use this second form right over
here
so our first term a is 24 so we're going
to have 24
times one minus our common ratio which
is one half
to the nth power well we're talking
about
the first n swing so i'm just going to
leave an n right over there
all of that over
1
minus our common ratio 1 minus 1 half so
we could leave it like that or we could
simplify it a little bit if we like one
minus one-half is equal to one-half 24
divided by one-half is equal to 48 so if
you wanted to you could simplify it to
48 times one minus
one-half to the nth power
so either of these would be legitimate
now the second part they say what is the
total distance the monkey has traveled
when she completes her 25th swing and
they say round your final answer the
nearest meter so pause this video and
see if you can work that out
all right well we can just use this
expression here and we know that we are
completing our 25th swing so n is 25 and
so we'll just put a 25 there so that's
going to be 48 times 1 minus 1 half to
the 25th power
now this is going to be a very very
small very very small number so it's
actually going to be pretty close to
48 meters but let's see what this is
equal to and we're going to round to the
nearest meter
all right so let's get our calculator
out and so let's just evaluate one-half
i'll just write that as 0.5
to the
25th power which as we said as we
predicted is a very small number and
then we're going to subtract that from 1
so let's put a negative and then i'll
add 1 to it
and so that is very close to 1 and so my
prediction is holding true so if i
multiply that times 48
well if we round to the nearest meter we
get back to 48 meters so this is going
to be
48 meters
and we're done